bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
premier set 8 sport de 2015 évidemment
tous nos meilleurs voeux sportif pour
ces douze prochains mois en attendant on
passe au sommaire de ce lundi 5 janvier
pas de nouvel exploit pour le basket
club de maurepas en 64e de finale de
coupe de france le bcm a dû s'incliner
face à caux pensionnaire de nationale 2
résumé complet
à suivre du 23 au 29 août prochain 29
août prochain ils seront six à parcourir
3 km entre le lac léman et la mer
méditerranée le long du rhône et le var
au now back calais 2015 organisée par le
vc au sky en mars prochain les enfants
seront la première de leur 4 4
destinations le désert et les dunes
après avoir bouclé leur budget d'ozil
ali et cendrés leur préparation pour le
rallye des gazelles 2015
évidemment en ce premier lundi de 2015
et quelques résultats de ce premier
week-end de championnat mais tout
d'abord place aux baskets et après son
exploit historique face à barjouville
que vous avez pu suivre
il y a quelques semaines en décembre le
basket club de maurepas avait l'occasion
de poursuivre son épopée en 64e de
finale de coupe de france face à caen
pensionnaire de nationale 2 mais cette
fois les quatre divisions d'écart était
de trop
résumé réalisé avec williams est si les
morts bazire débutent la rencontre avec
25 points d'avancé à cause de l'écart de
quatre divisions à la faveur de caen
leur avance fond comme neige au soleil
à la fin du premier quart le bcm ne mène
plus que de quatre petits points 33 29
avec six joueurs au delà des 2 m contre
un seul pour le bcm
la supériorité athlétique caennaise fait
logiquement la différence dans la
raquette
chaque panier devient alors un combat
pour les rouge et blanc mais grâce à un
gymnase mal me donne une nouvelle fois
omniprésent les joueurs d'alexis
dumontet continuent de se battre sur
chaque possession
malgré les 28 points d'avance pour caen
après trois quart temps on avait retenu
la leçon du tour précédent ont même avec
20 points d'avancé pour bompas il avait
été capable de venir
ce qu on a contre une équipe de
nationale 3 et donc on était peut-être
mieux on savait une salle chaude
on savait
une équipe qui joue avec enthousiasme et
on a surtout été vigilant
cette fois l'enthousiasmé les supporters
n'ont rien pu faire face à la
supériorité normande une équipe qui n'a
connu qu'une seule défaite en
championnat cette saison
score final 106 à 63 la défaite est sans
appel
mail aventures du bcm aura été belle
quand on rejoint l'équipe de caen qui
est quand même une grosse équipe de n2
ils sont à 39 victoires pour 4 défaites
sur les 2 dernières saisons
donc c'est vraiment une grosse une
grosse écurie voilà le score il est il
est important quand on perd 43 points
mais les joueurs sont battus ils ont
mouillé le maillot et c'est très
important et ce soir pour le premier set
8 sport de l'année 2015 je serai
accompagné d'eric castaldi est le
responsable de la section handisport du
bce skype pour nous parler évidemment de
ce bail run and bike challenge 2015
bonsoir à vous on le retrouve tout à
l'heure eric on enchaîne évidemment
aussi avec du volley-ball ça s'est passé
pendant ces vacances et le sport ne
s'arrêtait pas pendant les fêtes de fin
d'année dans le cadre de sa préparation
au championnat d'europe l'équipe de
france de volley ball des sourds
affrontaient les seniors de montigny le
bretonneux un match de gala synonyme de
retour aux sources également pour le
capitaine de l'équipe de france xavier
bnr reportages réalisés avec david
charpentier s'ils connaissent des
difficultés en championnat
les volleyeurs de montigny voit dans ce
match amical face à l'équipe de france
des sourds une occasion de se détacher
du combat pour le maintien face à un
adversaire de prestige
c'est un challenge parce que
bon on les connaît pas on ne connaît pas
on sait pas quel est leur niveau mais on
a envie quand même de venir faire
évidemment
voilà c'est quand même l'équipe de
franges des sceaux en juillet 2015 paris
accueillera le championnat d'europe des
sourds la sélection officielle ne
tombera qu'en février il reste donc
encore quelques places à prendre dans le
groupe tricolore
une équipe de france ambitieuse après sa
sixième place aux mondiaux de 2011 en
bulgarie voilà c'est effectivement
d'avoir une meilleure stratégie la
meilleure relation entre les joueurs
pour être beaucoup plus régulier parce
que dix jours de compétition avec des
matches tous les jours c'est important
de bien se connaître
l'objectif moi personnellement il est
clair c'est la meilleure place possible
mais bon après bien sûr dans les quatre
premiers
ce serait le mieux pour être qualifié
directement pour les jo dans les jeux
des flammes pics si cette rencontre et
amicale elle a une saveur toute
particulière pour des habits bnr c'est
un peu le retour aux sources pour le
capitaine de l'équipe de france passé
par montigny pendant trois saisons nous
expliquer ce qui sent les vibrations qui
sont les mouvements
par contre ils sont pas le bruit de la
balle il l'a pas et il entend pas à
droite à gauche et des fois on a les
anecdotes tout
tout le monde lui criait pour le prendre
comme un joueur oui j'ai la balle c'est
moi oui pour le dit mais pourquoi on
l'avait la balle et il se retournait en
rigolant dix ans elles seraient pas
entendues battu 3 sets 1 l'équipe de
france dispose encore de six mois pour
trouver la bonne formule qui lui
permettra de se hisser sur le podium des
championnats d'euros et on enchaîne avec
le cyclisme et le handbike je le disais
dans les titres de cette émission du 23
au 29 août prochain ils seront six à
parcourir 300 km entre le lac léman et
la mer méditerranée tout près de
montpellier le long du rhône c'est le
valium via un run and bike challenge
2015 et pour nous parler et nous
présente et surtout cet événement unique
à eric castaldi le responsable de la
section handisport du essieux sky est
présent sur le plateau du 7-8 sport
bonsoir
eric loin merci d'être là alors tout
d'abord expliqué noah un petit peu en
quoi ça consiste ce challenge c'est un
événement qui vont mener fils handicapé
avec six accompagnateurs sur les voies
vertes du rhône qui partent de genève à
palavas les flots
c'est un événement unique c'est la
première fois que six handicapés bon
faire le biarrot n'a donc pour nous
c'est une grande première
c'est un grand un grand moment pour
représenter les nouvelles couleurs du
club
le team vous sert voilà justement
l'objectif de ce challenge c'est quoi
c'est de montrer qu' il n'y a pas de
handicap dans le sport tout à fait le
premier but c'est de montrer qu'il n'y a
pas d'obstacles pour le handicap et
c'est de montrer à travers les étapes
sur les grandes villes qu'on va
traverser que nous handicaper on peut
être à la hauteur des valides
jusqu'aujourd'hui les validations même
très appliqué des perdantes des
performances qu'on fait voilà c'est
vraiment de montrer qu'aujourd'hui on
peut vivre normalement avec un handicap
pour rappel votre section hand bike qui
hélas premier la pionnière dans les
yvelines est la seule pour l'instant une
petite dizaine de passionnés comme vous
dévalent les routes
jus pour revenir sur la route de ce
challenge 2015 quel itinéraire précis
vous allez emprunter pour partie partir
du lac léman pour aller vers le midi on
va suivre les voies vertes jusqu'à aux
grandes villes lyon
après c'est châteauneuf avignon pour
arriver à palavas les flots et palavas
est plongée la méditerranée au soleil
pour arriver au grau du roi
ça va faire en tout sept jours de course
si l'on peut dire de challenge avec
cette ville étape à chaque fois ça a dû
être une logistique impressionnante à
mettre en place
c'est beaucoup de travail on est encore
en train aujourd'hui de chercher des
partenaires pour nous aider
sachant que les localités qu'on va
traverser sont très intéressés par le
projet donc j'ai pas de soucis grèce
encore deux trois mois de préparation
sinon le parcours est bouclée les villes
étapes et les hôtels sont pratiquement
réservé reste plus qu'à rouler
maintenant il reste plus qu'à évidemment
il ya des routes spécifique vous devez
emprunter avec le hand bike où vous
prenez les voies vertes comme vous le
disiez classique la grande nouveauté
dans le hand bike parce que lens
bakchich depuis longtemps la grande
nouveauté du club c'est qu'on est les
premiers à faire du vélo tout terrain
durant le bail tout terrain donc à
pouvoir traverser des des vignobles avec
notre bail tout-chemin monter des petits
cols travaillés des chemins de pierre
enfin voilà on prend vraiment les
chemins où on est chaud va pas
rencontrer de voiture pour être
évidemment tranquille 300 km en 7 jours
je le disais ça fait à peu près de 43 km
de moyenne par jour c'est un effort
considérable en bike
qu'est ce que ça peut représenter
aujourd'hui ça représente beaucoup de
kilomètres sachant que quand on
s'entraîne aujourd'hui on fait des 20 à
30 km à la matinée ou à l'après midi on
a fait plus mais là c'est sur une
semaine donc il va falloir préparer
sérieusement à paraître début mars dès
que les beaux jours vont arriver ces
deux à trois entraînements par semaine
c'est beaucoup d'entraînement y avoir un
entraînement spécifique justement en
tant que responsable de cette section
handisport vous allez mettre en place
des
des programmes spécifiques en vue du
jour j ce qui me rend aujourd'hui c'est
que oui à dix entraînements spécifiques
mais c'est pas nous les handicapés
qu'avant perse et nos accompagnateurs
qui se disent tu avais beaucoup de
kilomètres donc on va faire des
opérations spécifiques pour les
entraînements des opérations de
démonstration pour que les valides
comprenne bien
hop une opération de 21 mars justement
mesnil saint denis avec roche aux
coiffures les bouchons espoir pour
montre aux gens la difficulté de
l'entraînement et leur fait tester lui
rendent bac et là on a vraiment des gens
qui sont étonnés de voir les efforts
qu'on a à faire avec les braves
justement qu'est-ce que vous travaillez
concrètement à l'entraînement la
musculation aussi de la imagine beaucoup
de kilomètres parcourus est bon en somme
on n'entendait que les boss de la vallée
de chevreuse
donc on entend beaucoup de de cris dans
le petit peloton au pied des mais
bon on s'aperçoit qu'on arrive à les
monter et ce qui est surprenant c'est
qu'on voit les gens qui sont en vélo
normal s'arrêter il nous regarde et nous
prendre pour des extraterrestres quoi
mais c'est de l'entraînement musculaire
et beaucoup respiratoires aussi pour
revenir sur le message au delà de
l'objectif sportif il ya un message que
vous voulez faire passer à travers ces
300 km que vous allez parcourir tous les
six accompagné il avant de vos
accompagnateurs
le message primordial c'est de montrer
que handicapé on a pas d'obstacle et
qu'aujourd'hui on peut aller là où on
veut malgré notre handicap quoi c'est
c'est votre philosophie de vivre de vie
avoue justement depuis votre accident de
vtt
moi je vis avec les challenges ça c'est
le premier challenge par rapport à ce
qu'on veut faire après et tous ceux qui
viennent avec nous on les emmène effet
un challenge pour eux et leur famille
beaucoup d'accompagnateurs sont des gens
de la famille des handicapés devons être
là et retrouver une nouvelle vie à
nouveau sourire quoi pour moi c'est chez
tous les bonheurs du monde là de
l'aspect sportif
alors évidemment on peut ne pas il me
penser que ce sera juste un coup pour un
coût ce challenge ça sera une étape
peut-être pour un plus grand circuit en
plus grands tracés un plus grand
parcours par la suite tout à fait on est
déjà en train de pomper à 2016 on
reliant brest à bayonne par la côté
atlantique du coup maintenant et on a
déjà des partenaires qu'il faut
intéressé par le projet actuel
le projet de l'année prochaine donc
c'est vrai qu'on recherche toujours des
partenaires mais on a grand espoir avec
kirill fable président de vge sky de
pouvoir accomplir et de montrer de
nouvelles couleurs qui me vous sert à
tout le monde et pour moi que l'handicap
aujourd'hui fait pas un handicap pour
revenir sur cette édition 2000 tiens je
crois que vous venez tout juste d'avoir
un parent un petit peu particulier est
en tout cas très connu dans le monde du
sport on a l'accord écrit et verbales de
pub crois font qu'elle va traverser la
manche
voilà c'est notre nouveau parrain à la
nage
je remercie le magazine indispensable
justement qui nous a fait connaître des
personnalités dans le domaine de
l'handicap qui nous permette d'aller
encore plus loin dans nos épreuves et
dans notre challenge quoi merci beaucoup
et ring d'être passé sur le plateau du
7-8 sport on se donne rendez vous
évidemment cet été pour voir où ira ce
challenge donc via rhôna handball
challenge 2015 merci beaucoup
à très bientôt on enchaîne sans
transition avec le rallye raid et le
rallye des gazelles 2015
en mars elles enclencheront la première
de leur 4 4 destinations le désert et
les dunes
après avoir bouclé leur budget 2
yvelinoise alice et sandrine continuent
leur préparation pour le rallye des
gazelles 2015 nous les avons suivis lors
de leur stage de pilotage et de conduite
dans la boue pour être plus précis
reportages réalisés avec floriane
parfait le levier de vitesse semble
parfois capricieux mais chaque minute
passée à bord de leur 4 4 et pleine
d'enseignements
après avoir bouclé leur budget en vue de
leur participation au rallye des
gazelles 2015
alice et sandrine effectué ce jour là un
stage de pilotage
si pour l'instant l'équipage ne pratique
pas le sable mais plutôt la boue
francilienne cette session conduite
permettent aux rambo liten de découvrir
leur véhicule
pour le moment le vis très bien on
découvre des nouvelles sensations on
découvre un autre 4 4 qu'on a utilisé
qu'une seule fois la semaine dernière
pour le moment et on apprécie ces
nouvelles sensations de glissade
on se demande si on va passer mais ça
passe toujours novice en rallye il leur
faudra parcourir 2500 km et surtout
résisté neuf jours dans l'enfer des
dunes marocaines
car dans le rallye des gazelles la
navigation se fait à l'ancienne sans gps
si sandrine est plus à l'aise avec carte
et boussole et alice au volant chacune
prend ses repères à tous les postes
avant la course quand on en a besoin
encore on a encore besoin de préparation
il faut qu'on s'entraîne la halle
véhicule est immobilisé pendant un mois
pour pour la déco intérieure extérieure
il faut qu'on reprenne au mois de
février il faut qu'on reprenne un peu
les entraînements parce que même si je
pense qu'on se débrouille pour l'instant
pas trop mal on est encore passion de
nous et il faut qu'on
qu'on s'entraîne encore prochaine étape
un stage de navigation fin janvier pour
apprendre les bases d'une carte et d'un
compas avant le départ pour le maroc le
25 mars prochain
comme tous les ans la compagnie d'arc
d'elancourt a organisé en ce premier
week-end de janvier son concours annuel
de en salle de tir à l'arc plus de 350
archers se sont succédé sur le pas de
tir pendant deux jours une compétition
qualificative pour le championnat de
france qui aura lieu cette année à
vittel en février prochain et aussi qui
permettait d'obtenir un ticket pour les
championnats d'europe
pour les tous meilleurs mission
accomplie pour la nîmoise sandrine
vandionant qui s'est imposé chez les
femmes en arc à poulies et chez les
hommes victoire de christophe dussau
devant sébastien peineau si beaucoup
d'archers sont superstitieux avec les
couleurs pour se rassurer autour de leur
tir à l'arc sur le pas de tir ce n'est
pas le cas de sandrine vandionant les
coteaux au micro de william
pour ma part j'ai pas de gris gris ni
sur mon cas vous n'êtes ni sur mon nom
maintenant c'est vrai que l'arc et très
personnelle on essaye aujourd'hui
d'harmoniser les couleurs entre les
flèches l'arc et s'est adapté à chacun
et on
généralement choisi ce qu'on aime
quelles qualités faut être ce pourrait
être un bon tireur à l'arc que je dirais
avant tout de la concentration une bonne
coordination et de la patience parce que
comme tous quoi il faut beaucoup
d'entraînement et attendre attendre
attendre pour que les résultats viennent
évidemment pour cette première émission
de 2015 nous allons jeter un dernier
coup d'oeil dans le rétroviseur de ces
douze derniers mois nous vous avons
préparé un montage des moments sports
les plus forts de cette année 2014 avec
romain russe finit à la baguette
e
on a travaillé dur cette année c'est le
fruit disant trahi je suis très fier de
ça
on aura l'occasion de se côtoyer
d'échanger nos expériences c'est ça
qu'on veut aller chercher une médaille
aux jeux olympiques
tous ces petits détails là ça compte
alors nous aussi réussi à battre le
précédent on a pas meilleure forme
mondiale parce que les frais et publie
depuis neuf ans finale mais c'est
vraiment une grande saison
c'est une belle histoire j'espère
qu'elle va continuer parce qu'on va
partir dans une nouvelle aventure
il y aura quelques étapes à franchir
mais l on va savourer quand même ces
petits moments là
aujourd'hui c'était une bonne journée je
ne m'attendais pas à gagner
j'ai beaucoup de chance d'être assis à
côté de ce trophée
des parents et c'est seulement quand
forme qu'attendu
sincèrement qu'ils auraient pu a misé
une pièce sur nous mais bon c'est un
groupe qui travaille dur toute la saison
on est invaincu en championnat
c'est une récompense par rapport à tout
ce qu'on travaille depuis trois ans il
était âgé de 77 ans le pilote de formule
1 jean pierre beltoise est décédé ce
lundi 5 janvier à dakar au sénégal
victime d'un accident cérébral après des
débuts en moto discipline dans laquelle
il totalise à onze titres de champion de
france jean pierre beltoise démarrant 63
en 1963 une carrière dans le sport auto
jusqu'à la formule 1 où il signa trois
victoires dont la mythique succès à
monaco en 1972 il possédait également
une piste du côté de trappes qui portait
son nom depuis plus de 20 ans toutes nos
pensées vont évidemment à tous ses
proches
vous connaissez très probablement
l'émission la france a un incroyable
talent diffusée sur m6 c'est bien une
idée monteyne que nous vous avons fait
découvrir dans le 7-8 sport participe à
cette saison numéro 9 il s'agit de
perrine sanchez membre de l'équipe de
france de vol relatif championne du
monde en 2012 perrine sanchez et ses
coéquipières ont passé la première étape
de sélection début décembre battant le
record du monde du nombre de figures
réalisées en l'air soit un total de 47
évidemment nous vous ferons suivre c'est
son parcours et leur parcours tout au
long de cette émission
avant de nous quitter on passe à votre
traditionnel agenda du week-end est tout
d'abord oui il y aura au programme du
football féminin division d'honneur 6e
journée décalée montigny reçoit l'équipe
réserve de juvisy l'équipe
professionnelle qui évolue en d1 coup
d'envoi à 16 heures ce samedi 10 janvier
au stade de la couleur il y aura aussi
du rugby au programme fédéral de plus
tôt 11e journée plaisir reçoit le 4e
nantes à robert barran ce dimanche 11
janvier coup d'envoi à 15 heures
et évidemment le perse et tentera de
décrocher sa troisième victoire de la
saison et débuter 2015 de là
meilleure des façons c'est la fin de ce
cette fuite peut remercier encore une
fois de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
lundi prochain même lieu même heure
d'ici là excellente soirée sur tv